well south korea has introduced some of
its strictest covert measures so far to
cope with the omicron wave and while the
public has largely cooperated with
restrictions so far more voices are
calling for the freedom to go about life
as normal and say no to vaccines
including teenagers frank smith has this
report from seoul
south korean high school student yang
dae-rim and his friends don't want to
get vaccinated neither do many of the 23
000 followers of his youtube channel his
live streams emphasize risks associated
with vaccination while downplaying the
benefits and argue the government's
vaccine pass violates their human rights
no one knows what the future side
effects will be
questions about whether it is effective
or growing because there are many cases
of infection with delta variants and
omicron variants even after being
vaccinated so individuals should decide
whether or not to get the vaccine i
don't think it's right to be
disadvantaged for not being vaccinated
from february first teenagers will have
to prove
or a recent negative covid19 test to
enter libraries private academies cafes
and other facilities yang argues that
the government should be focusing its
efforts on the elderly and not the young
the high mortality rate of the elderly
can explain the justification for the
vaccination of the elderly
but the fatality rate for young people
is low
and yet the side effects of vaccines are
many
so i don't know why young people are
vaccinated
some south green parents have also
mobilized together with support from
some doctors to protest against the
vaccine pass a mother of five children
kim soo jin is even taking the case to
the country's courts
i think the vaccine pass policy is
against constitutional law it's a
serious violation of children's right to
learn and violates their right to
education because they can't go to the
library or private academies because of
the vaccine past
as south korea scrambles to provide care
for the record number of serious cases
h plus yangji hospital's 34 covet icu
beds are full
infectious disease department head eg
young says that while vaccines may cause
some side effects
he supports the vaccine pass and
stresses that the risks of infection for
the unvaccinated are far greater
vaccination prevents 60 to 90 of
infections and when a breakthrough
infection occurs
that person is 90 percent less likely to
die or require severe treatment
the media should not spread fake news or
insignificant news
but deliver the voice of medical
professionals to the public
for most south koreans the medical
community's message on vaccines and the
vaccine pass seems to be sinking in
i think that it's fair because
individual freedoms are guaranteed only
so long as they are not infringing upon
social safety
so i believe people should get
vaccinated as soon as possible to use
public places with a vaccine pass the
vaccine pass was introduced for adults
december 6th
south korea is now dealing with its
highest surge of the covid19 pandemic
with more than 5000 new cases per day
for weeks
as the debate over vaccines and a
vaccine pass for the nation's youth
continues the omicron variant may cause
those numbers to rise
jerome kem joins me now from soles the
director general of the international
vaccine institute an independent
non-profit international organization
based in seoul founded by the undp mr
kim thanks very much for joining us
clearly vaccine hesitancy is a problem
in south korea but it isn't only there
what more can be done to convince
vaccine skeptics
so as a as a medical professional we
always believe and i think you heard one
of the physicians earlier say
we need to have the right information
we actually need to do more than that
we've been presenting the correct
information about the ability of
vaccines to reduce infection
by five times to reduce hospitalization
and death by ten times
we can talk about the risk of
severe complications of cobit infection
in the unvaccinated uh versus the
vaccinated
and and we've talked about it and we
need to be forceful about that message
because omicron is adding a new level of
danger because it's coming on top of a
delta outbreak that has already filled
the hospitals in korea so we need to be
more forceful in the messaging we need
to change the messaging now you heard
about the newspapers and the television
but are those reaching the people
who we need to target now
the high school children the the kids in
high school so that young youtuber with
26 000 followers are we putting the
messages out there the correct messages
the ones that emphasize not only rights
but responsibilities
not only to protect yourself but to
protect others these children will be
going out and having and meeting their
family over the holidays are they going
to make sure that the people they meet
aren't going to be there a victim of
of lack of vaccination and lack of
protection that's true i mean obviously
the messaging is important combating
fake news for example is really
important but there are studies to show
that it doesn't in fact work to convince
people uh to by by telling them all the
statistics and showing them that that
getting vaccinated is a good thing i
mean especially if the root of vaccine
skepticism are more sort of moral
intuitions gut feelings etc what else
can be done apart from the messaging
so i think that this is where
governments have a number of tools
available to them and governments have
to be very careful about the way they
deploy these tools
but you know to some extent
what is the alternative
we have several alternatives we can
continue in masks and distancing
we can encourage or require vaccinations
or we can require vaccinations only if
you want to do particular things if you
want to go to these after-school
academies if you want to go to a
norikbang which is a korean version of
the karaoke
venue then you need you need to be
vaccinated but in addition to that you
know so so having these requirements
puts a restriction not on your ability
to do things but only on your ability to
do things that put your put you and
other people at higher risk right so
including social media
is important
exactly and i mean and we really you
know we talk about vaccines as the
solution vaccines are a part of a very
important part of a layered defense the
first line of defense is of course the
the things that people need to do right
the mask the distancing avoiding crowds
vaccines may be the second line of
defense after that we have medical care
well the medical care system is full now
so what other options does a country
have they can do as countries in europe
if then they can lock down again korea
is never locked down people have always
had music
sorry i'm sorry to interrupt you but
we're running out of time and i did want
to ask about whether or not this is
largely a first world problem in that
many people from richer nations where
vaccines have been readily available
don't seem to want to take them
do you see less hesitancy in developing
nations where they often
or perhaps frequently don't have access
to vaccines
so i think it's important to remember
though that the korea being a
high-income country does not have a big
problem with anti-taxers
so it also depends on the country but
yes
uh it's it tends to be less of an issue
but increasingly as the supply of
vaccines through kovacs and other
mechanisms is becoming greater we're
seeing the emergence of some resistance
to vaccination in lower and middle
income countries as well and this is
particularly problematic because some of
the other things that would support
patient care if a person became infected
are not present in in low-resourced
healthcare settings so it vaccination is
even more important and we need to work
again on messaging and getting
governments behind the idea that this is
a very important thing for everybody in
society
all right jerome king we'll have to
leave it there thank you very much
director general of the international
vaccine institute
you